[Musica]
a tutti oggi nuova cialente a
grandissima richiesta non lo challenge
con le stacca post vi è piaciuta
tantissimo l'altra college
quindi ho deciso di farlo inoltre come
abbiamo detto se raggiungerà i diecimila
life ne avremmo fatto un'altra è in
questo caso le sac à poche sono
misteriose vedete quasi subito per
recuperi noi andrebbe una ruota e
dovremo prendere il numero
corrispondente al sakka force
in più ci sono altri scambio che
ovviamente presi tutti come sempre fate
tv per me piace lo vediamo the us
capital verde perché ci sono due la
capoccia verdi
secondo voi a chi capiterà adottato come
sempre la stessa ex pds raggiunge i 10
anni online sapremo fare un'altra
challenge come stacca posti con una
ruota e sicuri di commenti polizia lange
volesse che facciamo nei prossimi video
le più belle andremo a farle mettetevi
comodi patatine pop corn e alla fine del
video potrete votare se ho vinto io
siamo in cubitale in più alla fine del
video viaggio con la schedina con il
sondaggio così potete votare e vediamo
direttamente i risultati nei commenti
però dovrete comunque votare il voto da
1 a 10 per affetto e persone mr
si possono mettere i punti da 1 a 10
però potrete votare
siamo in tre io siamo in italy così noi
vediamo la percentuale quindi mi
raccomando guardate il video fino alla
fine per votare
e allora siete pronti bene allora
vediamo un po
eccolo fatto numero 7 che giochi o
carotone mi sembra sempre caro apertura
di tirare su un canotto dalla terra
allora mi è capitato quello con lo
shampoo brocco di berlinesi sono anche
le perline con le letterine e in me
quindi molto interessante di ok allora
vada subito ad aggiungere la mia prima è
composto il mio contenitore quanti
glitter e quante decorazioni wow
questa le decorazioni con le letterine
non ho mai fatto uno slang con questa
decorazione tra l'altro profumo di
fragola e che cosa ne pensate
guardate un po bellissimo guerra di
questi tre gialli
quindi per ora iniziamo bene
16 rombo della top 16
ok primato è fatto per il numero non la
fa capo la maretta
sono fortunato 8 fatturato ma fornario
ti ricordi che cos'è numero 8 è
opportuno 38
ok allora prendi lotto su brenda barbara
fanno vedere andrea marrocco violetta
parlate mondo lorenzo metallo quindi
perché la chiama tratta di shopping
online
vediamo un po come se vado mai a tutto
no se stava esplodendo là dentro non
aiuta e non è neanche messo tutto certa
la gigantesco il tuo slany mostriamo
troppo che teheran dove la sperata
soprattutto nello show dove tutto penso
proprio perché strano poi colorante non
si è mischiato bene con licenza barp a
ripoli e tutto il veicolo ricordato
molti versi o rota sono stati tutta e tu
giallo e azzurro
finora il verde non è uscito tra passino
binari che numero è bene non ce lo
ricordiamo che tocca a me
vediamo lo scambio è a metà piace di più
questo allora a remi numeri fortunati
stone e di 27 15 sono entrambi con
quindi è complicato 2
chi non ha capito prima l'aveva preso
prima di presto prima che quindi devi
per forza proprio ultimo abete dobbiamo
prendere due vi dico perché il mio
numero preferito è davvero piccola
perché mi ricorda un cigno la forma
detto qual è sono detto prima 8 perché
grande è la forma di un 8
allora prende il numero 233 attaccati su
di lui quindi erano sta pure bene
lo sapevo ma serve cambiato il belgio ma
non tolgo il numero due alla stazione
delle foto c'è dentro almeno non è molto
punto perché dentro a
le fishbowl poi i glitter con le
stelline ed è una specie di verde chiaro
richard bruton over
vediamo cos'è la destra coperto con
caffè di via quest'acqua che belle le
fishbowl celesti queste col trasparente
quindi se non mi capita la colla bianca
potrebbe uscire molto carino questo
slime è cotta inter si sono tutte le
sterili
che bella effetto ora provo a mischiarli
di milk e ora dopo
forse è meglio dalla mischia 3 comunque
non è male
accanto decorazioni dentro vediamo di
che colore diventa mi sembra che il
verde non si veda più si vede più il
viola potevo più provo a safi è viva
meno male che non mi capita anche
l'altro verde sto a posto
bello bello mi piace ancora borioni è
capitato stop quindi non può toccare
niente
peccato fuoco travolgendo tutto quindi
prelevamento girato proprio a me
[Musica]
[Risate]
quali erano le possibilità che può
esistere entrambi tutto casuale con la
ruota mi sono usciti entrambi non ci
posso credere è portato subito io
all'inizio tutto che lo prenderete
settore verde e così è stato
bene quindi ho beccato il secondo veste
che per fortuna è nella colla
trasparente hillman ancora trasponendo
magari una mia rimarrà un bel tour che
soccorra solo la dalla schiuma da barba
quindi che devo attivare come appunto
guardate qua e con la trasparente verde
e brillantini perché ci possa coprire il
verde come mente speriamo dai verdi non
colorare tutto questo non colorarlo
tutto
[Musica]
questa volta non è detto devo ancora
mischiarli e vediamo se diventerà verde
almeno i glitter colorati nora verde
anche per però ecco fatto proviamo
fischiarlo e speriamo che non diventi
verde vi diamo 7 questa volta non riesce
sembra una palude adesso almeno
contingente no vabbè sta diventando il
vento è scaduto bellissimo da tito
marrone color marrero coca cola e
verderame ha passato il circo calcola
scaduta 9 gol e perderà coca cola alla
vaniglia bene rovinato completamente il
colore bellissimo rosso però guarda
quanti twitter
magari rimarrà comunque bello non si sta
[Musica]
marrone verde
radio
[Musica]
guardate i numeri allora abbiamo il papa
56 io scendo il vento che bello con la
piazza
trotta rosa è troppo il sun ci sono
anche dei piccoli bambini
sì forse si trovano meglio delle piccole
pagine rosa dovrà farla fissa e e mio in
dialetto dalla tregua al proprio con la
gavetta e la scambiamo non puoi mai
saperlo l'ultimo momento potremmo a
cambiarlo
magari misteri fate il tifo per me
rimane che tira la volata per dire il
cambio scambio cambio che ci saranno
però come diventerà rosa viola che ci
sia anche dal viola poi procedete giallo
novellino corona secondo voi
secondo me il celeste il celeste del gel
da barba in qualche modo poi andrà via
[Musica]
spero che colore s tra tra rosa blu e
giallo forse se per le tende
viola rosa giallo però tante palline di
un po più grande successo non c'entra
andiamo a vedere come esce colore
secondo me essendo verde non sto dicendo
non ho mai detto colore no aspetta
perché rosa deve ancora colorare tutto
quindi ha una consistenza un rosa antico
quale più bella figliola di mina e il
mio coca cola
facciamo finta che coca cola non marrone
prese un bravi bello quindi è riuscito
un rosa e grigio sono delle piccole
sfumature già testate le sfumature blu
della schiuma da barba pensa andranno
via quei programmi vediamo stesse lo
scambio a dover scegliere io abbiamo ben
io ho scelto qua
ho capito tutto allora questo numero 4 e
la neve in tazze da qua dentro il drive
marrone lo scopriremo molto presto però
speriamo che almeno questa neve finta
celeste perché forse lette
magari potrei allo slide che l'interesse
mediano un pò come ci sta questa hit no
piccato il pezzetto da alcol arco che
cola la maniglia color ruggine vediamo
un po oddio per seconda non mm tipo
ghiaccio sembra chiazzo che strano oggi
a cui diventerà questa cosa
stranissimo
vabbè magari diventa uno slide tendente
al marroncino grottaglie sono non
esserne per fango ma il fango slime la
consistenza dell'impasto di una torta
mischiamo la vediamo un po come diventa
addio delizioso dai fargli cambiare
cuore non sbaglio sta diventando sempre
più verde
no sta diventando cenette non lo vedi
sempreverde no in verde acqua strano
diciamo che un po particolare la
consistenza nuovo mai fatto uno snow
slime con la colla trasparente o almeno
è diventato un pozzo destino non c'è più
quel colore marrone blu viso grazie alla
mia scelta che poi doveva arrivare
all'altro l'altro sicuramente meglio ma
non è detta l'ultima parola perché può
essere che ve lo scambiamo allora sono
rimasti due numeri il 3 e il 5
vediamo si deve ritirare perché abbiamo
aperto e cappuccio quindi non prendi
niente quindi sicuramente un po però io
quelli gambe o in cartone arancione chi
era lì con trasparente in film guardate
quanti glitter ha dentro anche la frutta
è qua sotto a le conchiglie di borse
chiuse migliorerà delibera e sogna un
altro colore diciamo adesso che cosa
esce
vediamo un po tu no il pezzo dentro
nuovamente o che bell effetto a tea
party che gigante questo flaiano adesso
ora scende la frutta
guardate pezzetti di frutta che belli e
anche il glitter
wow ora vediamo
perché andavano mischiarli e magari
diventa loro universo diventare mondiale
stima che solo ingrediente schiuma da
barba e con la bianca punta il mio è
prestissimo ma perché ce l'aveva dire
allora vediamo un po di colore di quanto
mi dire che fa tornando marrone
tutto inutile dice è tornato marrone
martino e anche il pezzo da sfatare
questo mi schiero al tema lo slime a 7
l'ultimo sarà facilissimo numerosi
scritti tutti curati da allora andiamo
il celeste acqua con le palline pianiste
acqua verde acqua anche se sembra
celeste celeste con le palline bianche
la colla biagio dall'effetto queste
anche le palline che sono le palline che
anche questa super che lanci pazzi
gradisce perché da sempre posizioneranno
alcune pari a sistemi castrate però
bisogna vedere che colori diventa
ma che faccio un taglio un pochino più
grande vediamo di colore diventa però
colore con lamiera books e vediamo di
che colore esce abbiamo il giallo e rosa
e celesti giallo è giallo che stava nel
primo ingrediente però era mai stato il
grigio così a me non vincerai tv anche
questa volta forse vincere lo stesso
non lo so dipende da come diventeranno
una volta atti canale cadono in rovina
del colore e il mio la palude dato il
nome mio slime penso una cosa tipo la
palude o il lago scaduto invece il tuo
come lo chiami greggio è ok ragazzi ora
andiamo ad attivarli come sempre e poi
ve li facciamo vedere bene che abbiamo
quadratura così poi potrete votare in
volta da una 10 per aspetto e per sony s
merda che i ragazzi abbiamo attivati
aramini facciamo vedere meglio ciò
potete vedere i colori mi è diventato un
violetto molto delicato che mi è
diventato verde campionissimi tra
grigione per te ti ho detto guardi
meglio allora ve li facciamo vedere
meglio adesso poi mi chiamo il sondaggio
poi potete votare allora tolga dalla
ciotola innanzitutto il bello grande
ecco qua lo slam i'm allora di positivo
che cosa che si vedono le decorazioni
dorate si vedono le palline e di litter
e qua ci sono delle fishbowl celesti
facce una coniglietta rossa insomma un
bel po di decorazioni il colore come
potete vedere è verde ovviamente la mia
spicca
la mia moda edizione è tornata e ora mi
faccio sentire un po di suoni allora è
tutto di cona trasparente non c'è né
schiuma né crema quindi i suoni sono
fuori sono solo quelli dove con la
trasparente quindi più che altro passoni
poking quindi dategli un voto da 1 a 10
per l'aspetto e per sony a sm ora sembra
grigio grigio morto in realtà violetta
violetto molto chiaro adesso lo tolgo i
ve lo faccio vedere e superflash bello
allora dunque questa lo slime è super
soffice morbidissimo molto elastico
stato attento ad attivarlo per attivarlo
troppo se ci sono ci sono le palline
bianche e le palline rosa all'interno si
possono intravedere e super super
morbido e bellissimo farà anche
tantissimi i suoni belli non vogliamo
non vediamo l'ora di vedere un po kings
lei ha dichiarato il mio poco cominciata
quella pallina
questo non è accaduto il ruolo il lo
slime molto bello e fatto con la schiuma
la colla bianca che il colore giallo
giallo rosso rosso rosa giallo blu e
rosa
mi raccomando hashtag invitata entrato a
fare il po king si come no guarda si
vede che ho imparato bene ma perché non
funziona
passiamo ai suoni scoppiettanti
[Applauso]
suoni che rimane comunque super elastico
sottotuta due palline ma perché le
palline sono molto grossi abbiamo fatto
la famosa che che tira di harare
bellissima perché quindi greggio inteso
come gioia grigio perché raiola è
bellissimo che mi raccomando votate e
soprattutto ricordatevi della città
anche un mi dispiace anita questa volta
addirittura dai commenti li vedo ragazzi
faccia apparire ora ho paura non mi
ricorda che lato appare il sondaggio
cliccate e cliccate chiamato anita
vitale slide dicendo qui è perché
comunque dietetica mar adentro stilista
andrò a vedere quindi votate votate
votate votate l'italia tiene sinceri e
poi nei commenti scriveteci bot da una
10 come aspetto e ei suoi meno persone
che ho fatto sentire bellissimi è il poc
in più soprattutto 4 castelli su queste
cliccare per vedere le nostre altre
fallen si nutrì tra fc dopo il video
divertenti a schemi cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao ciao